on a pensé qu'un astronaute pourrait
nous montrez nous enseigner donner des
conseils pour les aider à mieux vivre
cette période de stress dont on parlait
au sélectionneur lupien tout à l'heure
je rejoins l'avis de singer qui est
actuellement chez lui à houston au texas
dans confinement avec sa famille bonsoir
david saint-jacques merci de prendre le
temps de nous parler
vous êtes vous-même donc en compliment
parce que vous rêvez de voyage mais
cette fois ci au moins vous êtes en
famille vous n'êtes pas dans l'espace
loin des vôtres sont également avoué oui
bonsoir bonsoir merci de me recevoir
je sais que c'est très difficile pour
beaucoup de gens c'était cette situation
là une troupe par saint françois à la
légère
nous comme vous dites on a la chance
d'avoir un peu d'expérience comme
famille de comment survivre sainement en
paix de d'isolement comme ça quelques
petites leçons qu'ils ont apprises au
fil du temps
d'abord il faut garder la perspective
large de pourquoi on fait ça quand ça
devient un peu pénible se rappeler c'est
quoi la mission qu'on a un enfant et en
même temps se concentrer sur le
quotidien sur les petites choses
il y avait à bord de la station par
graffiti lomé notes laissées sur le mur
par un astronaute ya longtemps qu'ils
disaient n'y a rien de plus important
qu'est ce que tu fais maintenant et ça
ça va ça m'a toujours aidé et je me
répète souvent cette phrase loca mon
esprit vagabonde à vouloir autre chose
qu est ce qui compte vraiment c'est ce
que je fais ce que je fais maintenant
que c'est important
perspectives et en même temps se
concentrer sur la mission on a ensuite
baissé la routine 1 il faut un autre
besoin de routine un peu conséquente on
sait tous que c'est important pour les
enfants mais c'est plus important pour
les adultes garder une séparation scène
entre le travail et la vie personnelle
même si physiquement même endroit et
moyens dans sa tête de créer une
distinction
comment s'habille l'éclairage ce qu'on
fait déclarer maintenant c'est fini le
jour de travail pas trop s'exposer aux
nouvelles assez pour être bien bonjour
quel sens aurait déformé
informé à des bonnes sources pour bien
rationaliser les vrais risques et de
vraies situations mais une fois qu'on
est au courant on est au courant il faut
passer aussi alors à la vraie vie est
resté prend soin de soi même
francine soi même à bien manger dormir
faire d'exercice pas oublier tout ça
fourmille et à organiser et finalement
peut-être retrouver le plus important
c'est de rester en contact
virtuellement c'est pas possible en
personne et donc quand je peux dire on
t'oublie le sacrifice qu'on fait pour
soi même en se concentrant sur les
autres en pensant à prendre soin des
autres et ça je pensais des valeurs que
les canadiens et les québécois
comprennent spontanément il ya une
source de plaisir de satisfaction puis
une source de confort là dedans sans
s'occuper des autres
d'autres s'occupent de nous nous le
ferons ouais c'est sûr mais le pas il
faut pas nier c'est vraiment difficile
de s'habituer cette situation là
d'autant plus qu'ils aient beaucoup de
gens pour qu'ils cèdent les conséquences
économiques désastreuses si on pense on
pense bien sûr besoin parce que le
message de québec s'est fait chacun ce
que vous avez à faire part c'est une
question de vie ou de mort
ce que vous avez vécu avec des grands
risques où s'ils ont servi dans l'espace
vous risquiez votre vie le camp vous
même vous sortir dans l'espace
juste des maris faire revenir de là sur
terre des gestes et risquer votre vie
comment le combattre cette anxiété la
chatte par là parce que le discours
s'est en même temps vous pouvez sauver
des vies c'est une question de vie ou de
mort restent floues
le message est assez pénétrant d'après
vous oui c'est un bon point
effectivement une meute ils assoient
d'autres extrêmement dangereux et
l'environnement à qui l'on vit dans
l'espace c'est absurde que mouss est
dangereux mais si on est con si on fait
juste pensé à ça évidemment on est
pétrifié but 1 1 alors qu'on ignore le
danger mais on lui fait face de manière
sobre et lucide on évalue réellement le
risque et puis on prend les moyens et on
se dit qu'est ce que je ferais si
quelques jeux seraient dans ce cas si
dans ce cas là une fois qu'on a fait le
tour de la question
on passe à autre chose et
ouais oui c'est important il faut être
lucide face aux risques qu'il faut pas
le nier mais il faut pas le permettre de
nous dominer c'est alors la part c'est
juste la poste un signe qu'on est lucide
mais c'est un conte est conscient mais
vous voyez
- vous réalisez un rêve quand même donc
vous pouvez vous consoler à dangereux je
réalise le rêve de ma vie
les autres lui vivent quelque chose
auquel il y aurait jamais personne n'a
pu imaginer la situation actuelle
génération incidence président s'en
aller mourir à la guerre l'on nous
demande de rester chez nous et malgré
cela ça génère énormément d'angoissé et
de peur oui vous savez l'angoissé bien
souvent des situations sur lesquelles on
n'a pas de contrôle
c'est lorsqu'on a l'impression qu'on
peut rien faire pour admirer d'autres ça
c'est là que surtout je trouve que
l'accepter que nous dominer et sans peut
se raisonner là dessus parce que c'est
qu'on réponde pas le contrôle en othe
collectivement individuellement et
collectivement on a des outils pour
améliorer nos chances de minimiser les
impacts de cette endémie là et c'est un
peu l'envers de la médaille de la
mondialisation d'avoir un taux courants
si ça avait été un autre époque on n'a
même pas eu tous coureurs que ça va
commencer ça nous aurait pris par
surprise
maintenant au courant ça se propage vite
à cause de mondialisation 6 mai donc
coûté nouveaux outils nous pouvons nous
permettre de nous en sortir
moi je suis fier en fait faire des êtres
humains
la forme a pris le taureau par les
cornes d'avoir de faire des sacrifices
pareil en termes économiques surtout
individuellement je pense qu'on fait la
bonne chose à leur bien être pas en
regardant en arrière d'avoir avoir été
aussi nous c'est râpé de réagir et aussi
prudent mais c'est pas facile s'est
passé parce que ce nouveau cd nouvelles
circonstances de vie pour beaucoup de
gens plein de conséquences très pénible
pratique est évidemment il ya du danger
un danger médical et ma conjointe
travaille en santé publique
donc on est on est très souvent on là
dedans est en plein dedans temps plein
et mais quand même vivre comme joutes
les enfants faut qu'ils continuent à
apprendre à lire et à écrire
il faut continuer à vivre c'est un il
faut jongler il faut aujourd'hui tout ça
c'est pas facile mais on est capable
votre conjoint et et la santé publique
vous avez été dans le grand nord est en
santé publique aux états unis en ce
moment ouais alors mais tous moments de
l'eau travaille actuellement comme tout
le monde c'est surtout de la
coordination la réparation parce que ça
fait cent au québec et aux états unis
vous êtes tous courants quoi moi je suis
con fini ici je suis au centre spatial à
la nasa prend ça très au sérieux
évidemment on veut absolument protéger
leur bulle le saint des saints le centre
des opérations
les équipages signé on veut s'assurer
que des dernières questions parce que
les gens vont vivre en confinement des
poissons nombreux vous vous avez vécu
collé collé collé sur des gens vous
connaissiez vous aviez après les connais
tous allés tous les rings très discret
les coûts tout cela tu conseilles
termine à 2 contre elle a quand même pu
y voir un peu plus loin en fait c'est
vraiment important de conserver une
petite bulle chacun d'avoir un endroit
où on peut se réfugier de respecter
mutuellement le besoin que tout le monde
à des degrés divers d'être un peu seul
nous les enfants nous dit dans leur
enseigner à nous dire quand est ce que
tu es tout seul et du monde te laisse
tout seul dit voilà les adultes aussi
doit faire ça faut pas juste par
politesse tolérer d'âneries apporter ça
me tente pas il ya certaines important
d'avoir pour la santé d'esprit en étant
des êtres humains on a besoin des autres
monnaies aussi besoin d'être un peu seul
chacun son équilibre différent ils sont
plus que la guerre donc sont plus seuls
d'art mais tout le monde n'a pas besoin
des deux camps vie confinée
important de respecter la bulle des
ordres de respecter les préférences des
autres c'est des efforts qui valent
vraiment la peine d'être fait ce six
mois que les raisons pour les missions
spatiales s'est parfois ça le défi
principal réussir à s'en tirer de
revenir de l'espace d'avoir encore en
vie deux mois c'est ce merci beaucoup
beaucoup depuis houston
david saint jacques au plaisir de vous
reparler c'est un privilège de vous
avoir reçu sur le plateau mais parce
qu'être sont autant merci virtuellement
merci beaucoup d'admiration invitation à
tous vos auditeurs je sais que c'est
très difficile pour bien des gens ont
pensé vous on est capable les reliant